didier deschamps va rappeler car il
faisait ma en équipe de france c'est sûr
daniel c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr ah
c'est sûr mais comment ça s'est passé
on a encore les les éléments de langage
entre les deux mais évidemment qu'il ya
eu rencontre et il y a eu
ils se sont ils se sont parlé et c'est
forcément après leur rencontre et leur
échange que ce à la demande du guide et
le retour est ce qu'on doit appeler une
réconciliation puisque finalement dans
cette histoire on parle beaucoup de
tours contre qui et pour qui est content
mais finalement c'était une affaire
personnelle entre deux hommes parce
qu'on n'avait pas réellement être pour
ou être contre deschamps en voulait à
benzema pour ce qu'il avait dit à
l'époque deuxième sélection le retrait
de ces îles avec mais d'abord on doit le
comprendre
voilà et je pense qu'à sa place j'aurais
été extrêmement blessée parce que même
si c'était un direct être traité de
raciste comme ça et en plus d'être une
personne sous influence qui aurait cédé
une partie raciste de la faim moi c'est
des propos qui ne m'aurait pas plu après
que la rancune et durer si longtemps et
surtout qu'en cinq ans il n'ait jamais
trouvé le moyen de se parler pour
aplanir et régler le différend c'était
ça finalement quitté sa surprise en café
que didier deschamps a repris contact
avec va cesser c'est pas si dan qu'il va
non je ne sais pas et ça va être
intéressant de voir comment ils vont
mettre en scène nous expliquait on n'est
pas sûr de dire la vérité en tout cas on
prendra ce qu'ils nous diront alors
est-ce que c'est deschamps qui a appelé
benzema ce que c'est benzema qui
appelait les champs je pense qu'ils vont
faire en sorte de garder la face l'un et
l'autre merci n'oublions pas qu'il y a
quand même puisque c'est une des
qualités qu'on attribue le plus à
deschamps une part de pragmatisme ça et
voir d'opportunisme sans que ce soit un
gros mot l'équipe de france lors des
derniers matchs a pas plu à deschamps
c'est vrai il avait une petite
inquiétude sur le niveau des attaquants
en vue de l'euro le groupe degré de
l'équipe de france à l'euro est très
difficile il peut y avoir eu aussi dans
la tête de deschamps
l'allemagne sera puisée maquis en train
de tout péter cette année ouais ce sera
un plus pour nous il n'a jamais dit je
ne reprendrais jamais benzema 21 ans il
a choisi la survie alors c'est vrai que
j'en avais parlé avec didier deschamps
déjà beaucoup il le sait et c'est vrai
qu' il ait pas de rancoeur contre karim
benzema il avait vu c'était extrêmement
blessé et sa famille aussi
voilà deux qui avait été dit et c'est
vrai que ça l'était
mathis main pour didier parce que disent
ils est tellement ouvert voilà c'est
quelqu'un je vous dis d'une simplicité
deschamps est ouvert il pense caringo
les isp on se prend pas la tête avec ça
et ça ça l'avait blessé un gitan boucau
d'autant que sa maison à concarneau
avait été taguée avec le mot raciste à
l'état vaut de benzema même pour sa
famille c'est indigne contre sassafras
me voilà pour deschamps la famille c'est
sacré dès qu'on touche à la famille ont
beaucoup de jours la famille je ne
connais avec la famille j'en ai rien à
celui qui les a rapprochés c'est quand
même le président de la fédération noël
le graet qu'a joué le rôle
d'intermédiaire pour que la brouille
s'estompe pour tout ce qui est qui entre
deschamps et benzema noël le graet noël
le graet il a toujours fait tout le
contraire noël et locales
c'est quoi cette oreille il s'est
mouillé pour la réconciliation vous
verrez vous le verrez dans les prochains
jours alors le graet a joué les
intermédiaires pour les réconcilier
absolument pas j'ai entendu des fous
daniel non mais y'a pas que c'est fou
cette affaire il ya pas de ces faux j'ai
eu l'occasion et en plus l'agent
historique et amie de karim benzema est
venu dans notre émission l'after foot
karim djaziri il nous a fait écouter un
sonore je les écoutais avec mes oreilles
dont je suis pas complètement fou gilles
ou noël le graet dit qu'il ne fera rien
pour les rapprocher qui n'interviendra
pas fou mais vous êtes sourd
je ne tombe pas jean bessière pour vous
c'est une mauvaise idée le retour de
karim benzema
alors mon opinion et volley-ball
estimant par le monde opinion sur les
talents footballistiques de karim
benzema que je reconnais volontiers et
c'est un très grand joueur
ah ouais il à marie leila recordman de
buts c'est moi je n'ai pas de problème
avec ça techniquement quand j'ai vu
certaines de ses actions cc c'est
magnifique c'est pas du tout là dessus
que je vais me faire aider
ben j'ai exactement mais ce qui me gêne
si vous voulez c'est que là on est en
train de parler de l'équipe de france
alors l'équipe de france c'est pas
simplement comment dirais-je une équipe
de football on est dans la
représentation il représente la france à
l'étranger il représente la france en
europe
c'est quelque chose l'équipe de france
est une des rares institutions dans
laquelle tout le monde se reconnaît
encore quelles que soient les origines
sociales professionnelles ethnique et
donc je veux qu'il y ait dans l'équipe
de france des gens qui incarnent la
france
or excusez moi mais quand karim benzema
en 2006 nous dit que son pays c'est
l'algérie nous dit qu'il veut pas jouer
qu'il aurait volontiers joué en algérie
mais que sportivement comprenez pour une
histoire d'argent il préfère jouer en
france lorsque il ne chante pas la
marseillaise lorsque il crache par terre
après la marseillaise jouée en l'honneur
des morts du bataclan mois ces choses là
me choque ça n'enlève rien à ses talents
mais je dis que ces choses là mais choc
une dernière chose quel pays au monde à
commencer d'ailleurs par son pays
d'origine c'est à dire l'algérie
accepterait dans son équipe nationale
un joueur qui ne chante pas son hymne
national ou qui crache par terre après
l'hymne national je crois que les
algériens et ils ont raison sont très
nationalistes très patriote et il
n'accepterait pas dans l'équipe
nationale
un joueur qui fait un tel affront à
l'hymne et au drapeau du pays je ne vois
pas pourquoi la france devrait
effectivement céder à cela
daniel riolo alors il ya trois points
dans ce que vous dites nationales
affaire du crachat c'est un fake avait
rennes mais c'est qu'il faut équiper 10
ans parce que c'est de là bas si beau
sa porte pour le foot je veux bien que
ces primes bref c'est un fake
la déclaration à laquelle vous faites
allusion sur en gros des propos que
tiennent tous les binationaux c'est
quelque chose que vous entendrez chez à
peu près tout le monde moi aussi à
l'époque les propos m'avaient un petit
peu interpellé mais finalement quand on
se renseigne récemment abdou diallo qui
est un joueur du paris saint germain qui
a fait toutes ses classes avec les
sélections équipe de france a finalement
opté pour son pays enfin le pays
d'origine de ses parents le sénégal les
binationaux sont tous déchirée par des
délits s'ils choisissent mais sur le
terrain on a le droit en fait des mais
c'est comme tous les binationaux
ghoulian on peut y mettre deux pays oui
mais il aurait très bien des juifs mais
l'algérie moi si oui j'en ai marre de ce
raisonnement qui consiste à dire que
pour que pour aimer l'autre il faut
commencer par se détester soi même
2 ainsi on peut aimer les deux jambes je
suis d'accord et oui mais on n'est pas
obligé si vous voulez d'être dans la
provocation vis-à-vis enfin excusez moi
mais karim benzema qui l'a fait roi
c'est quand même la france oui donc on
lui doit au moins à défaut d'allégeance
il le doit au moins un million de
rescapés le france et en équipe de
france si c'est toujours bien bien non
j'espère que sa province est réservée
aux films à faire dans une équipe
nationale dans l'équipe tricolore il
vous est pas foutu de chanter l'hymne du
pays que vous représentez hervé mathoux
et l'or
si on enlève les joueurs qui ne sont pas
les animaux nationale mais ça met plus
le ballon mais plusieurs erreurs font
pas une vérité un plusieurs erreurs font
pas une vérité et d'autre mais les
autres ne chante pas que mon que lui
jean jaurès est engorgé le problème si
vous mélangez plein de dossiers alors il
y en a qui sont faits qui en a on essaye
non s'étendre après leur arrivée à
marseille
le problème que ça soit fait de la
marseillaise c'est que ça peut nous
prendre toute une soirée
si on a pas dans ce pays plus
globalement éduquer même à l'école les
gens à savoir ce qu'est la marseillaise
c'est vrai quoi c'est bien de la chanter
c'est vrai on va pas aller reprocher un
joueur de foot non mais vous pouvez pas
ne pas la chanter aussi ça chagrine
autres ça me chagrine que ce soit plus
fait dans d'autres pays le perçu en
france
mais si on n'explique pas à l'école et
si on abandonne depuis 30 ans maintenant
oui ce qui est relatif à la nation et à
la ministre gros partis extrémistes
les problèmes suivants monde a confié un
autre débat matériaux concerne pas que
karim benzema mais vous savez vous avez
parfaitement raison ce que de tout ce
que vous avez dit je n'enlèverais pas
une virgule vous avez parfaitement
raison à mais maintenant est ce qu on
institutionnalise cette capitulation non
milieu type n'ont absolument pas en
mettant à 105 équipe de france le
résultat de sa non ouest au contraire on
exacerbe les équipes de réserve l'équipe
de france a de vrais patriotes quelques
problèmes etc l'histoire l'a dit de l'or
et et d'hervé l'or non moi je suis hyper
contente de le retour de karim benzema
c'est vrai que j'ai fait j'ai perdu une
place de l'église est jeune mais quand
t'es pas là pour ça ouais j'aime quand
j'ai vu la lymphe où c'est vrai que je
savais qu'on allait le côté politique à
l'ailé ça ressemble et c'est ça qui me
dérange c'est parce que biarritz est
fantastique quand tout le monde a un
avis sur karim benzema même ceux qui
pileux qui ne connaissent pas s'incliner
non mais l'ajustement sur une copie en
fait c'est un mec qui porte le c1 mais
qui porte le real exemplaires on l'a vu
sur le terrain mais en perd aussi
andorre je pense que en dehors n'a
toujours nerveux c'est un amour de m je
pense que
[Rires]
est ce que quelqu'un de cracher ses
normes
je savais qu'il allait me faire mal aux
oreilles hervé qu'est ce qu'on pensait
autocad
c'est quelqu'un de cracher jumeaux libre
messieurs non et si non mais vous
pourrez admirer son geste qui dérange
couvent transformé en vrai que c'est pas
un fake un verbe et matthew bennett
ilaina cracher comme tous les joueurs
sachent constamment effectivement il ya
eu un montage pas le moine mais c'est
excitant non non pas du tout pas du tout
s'est avéré il n'a jamais craché pour
signifier qu'il crachait sur la
marseillaise
donc ça c'est votre interprétation
monsieur rang local c'est la vôtre
conserver comme étant ceux des gestes
c'est une boutade harvey ou pas alors
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle on
verra quelque part la compétition ne le
dira mais c'est quelque chose que tous
les footeux a pas ou il tendait la forme
de sa vie et une équipe de france qui en
a besoin et deux hommes dont on pensait
qu'il pouvait dialoguer et ce dialogue
ne se faisait pas il s'est fait c'est
heureux c'est une nouvelle gerald de
drogue adore le foot cette théorie c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
qui l'eût cru moi c'est une question de
football / tu portes sur le football oui
j'ai toujours entendu bien que le
problème de karim benzema sait que c'est
un joueur de génie mais qui ne jouait
pas collectif extase une équipe c'était
un problème est là revers il l'a prouvé
cette année c'est à peu près tout
l'inversé le quand il était à l'étrat
star c'était ronaldo il a d'abord été un
peu joueur de l'ombre
et ensuite quand ronaldo est parti c'est
devenu un leader c'est qu'un quart des
nouvelles règles également les questions
passe par moi c'est une triangulaire ce
qu'on appelle une triangulaire ces
conditions on peut juste deux secondes
je sais pas par qui ça a été abordée
tout à l'heure mais on dit que autour de
benzema tout le monde a un avis parce
que il ya une tension un petit peu
politique voilà il ya une dimension un
petit peu politique moi je trouve et
tous les soirs moi je regarde souvent
l'émission tous les débats toutes les
autres chroniqueurs préférés
enfin donc et votre chronique aux knicks
le climat le climat sociétale en france
est extrêmement tendue on est pris dans
une dans une taille aujourd'hui qui est
en gros l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche tous les débats tournent autour
de sa quille et raciste qui n'est pas
raciste tout le monde s'accuse sans
arrêt de sa est accusé de racisme par
l'extrême en tôle et serait moche mais
les deux minutes de georgie en clientèle
[Rires]
mais c'est pour ça que jamais de raciste
ari ont sauvé sia c'est pour ça que
j'avais trouvé les propos de benzema
déplorable à l'époque et c'est pour ça
que s'il a dit daniel ainsi moi je dis
que je vous dit quelque chose de
désobligeant mais qu'après je vais
m'excuser j'ose espérer que vous allez à
m'excuser moi j'ai donc à partir moment
que j'ai vu il ya un dialogue et ce que
je vois moi dans cette décision c'est
une volonté de dialogue et de
réconciliation si on pouvait sortir mais
dans tous les débats aujourd'hui parce
que de cette taille dans laquelle on
veut nous enfermer entre l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche en gros ce
qu'est ce qui s'accusent mutuellement
d'être raciste les légendes du
rassemblement national et les islamo
gauchiste ça serait plutôt bien et je
veux voir dans leur appel alors
peut-être que je suis un petit peu naïf
mais le rappel de benzema en équipe de
france d'un petit peu politisée à mon
cerveau moi je pense précisément que ce
rappel la pose problème il fait déjà
endémique pour deux raisons c'est normal
parce que c'est vrai ça rit ça rejoint
d'autres intérêts que vous vous êtes
dans le manche de la taille c'est pas du
tout pas dit que si je laissais gens
mais ça il ya didier deschamps
l'équivalent annoncé jeudi je dis
simplement que karim benzema si vous
voulez on n'a pas l'équipe de france n'a
pas vraiment besoin de lui parce qu'elle
a regagné déjà la coupe du monde bon moi
je préfère une équipe de france qui
gagne avec des joueurs qui sont français
jusqu'au bout des ongles
bessac platini n'était pas jusqu'au bout
des ongles bien sur scène et non mais
moi je considère que quelqu'un comme
paul pogba par jour pour les français et
je l'adorais alors babel salamane il n'a
jamais craché soirée benjamin benzema
resté pourquoi vous avez une conception
raciale quand je dis moi je suis
français jusqu'au bout des ongles j'ai
pas d re lancer dessous je suis pas
gaulois ou alors si vous êtes très
élégant